while spider-man into the spider-verse
is totally suitable for children it has
some truly great moments that older
viewers can appreciate moments that
likely swung right over the kiddies
heads these are some of the things that
only adults will notice and into the
spider-verse
into the spider-verse feels like a movie
that is fully aware of the fact that
it's inspired by a comic book the film
begins with an introduction from Peter
Parker
well a Peter Parker as we later meet a
couple different versions of him if you
pick up on the context clues you can
determine that the Peter from the
beginning of the film is actually Tobey
Maguire's spider-man from the original
Sam Raimi trilogy the film smartly
displays animated versions of scenes
from those movies including Peter
stopping the runaway train in 2004's
spider-man 2 and even his weird dance
from 2007 spider-man 3 rumor has it that
Sony actually even considered casting
Maguire to voice this version of Parker
before ultimately settling on Chris Pine
beyond that Peter goes on to brag that
he's been featured on a slew of various
merchandise including a comic book a
serial social bobble he also mentions
that he has an excellent theme song
which fans of the early animated cartoon
shows can certainly vouch for while this
surplus of Spidey stuff is sure to give
older fans fits of nostalgia you have to
wonder how much of it went unnoticed by
the younger generation after miles is
bit by the radioactive spider his body
starts to change he wakes up the next
morning and notices that his pants are
now too short because he grew in height
seeking an explanation
he wonders if he's possibly going
through puberty later he finds himself
noticeably sweating while trying to pull
off uncle Aaron's shoulder touch pick up
move with when when she asks him
straight-up why he's so sweaty he tells
her it's a puberty thing he continues to
stick with this story throughout the
scene even when his newly acquired
spider grip gets stuck in Gwen's hair
causing her to exclaim I don't think you
know what puberty is the scene is
humorous to adults because they know
that obviously puberty has nothing to do
with gaining spider powers and
everything to do with the awkward
teenage Earnest that inspired miles to
try out Uncle Aaron's move in the first
place however for a kid who hasn't gone
through puberty
they might
fully grasped the outlandish nature of
miles assessment if only it truly did
grant you superpowers better than acne
and Bo right you don't have to be
Sherlock Holmes to immediately figure
out that in into the spider-verse
miles uncle aaron was going to play an
important role in the young hero story
fans of the comics knew that he was
actually the Prowler but even if you
didn't know that going in it became
pretty obvious early on that good ol
uncle Aaron had a few tricks up his
sleeve however when you consider that
this is a spider-man movie the term
uncle should be a red flag everyone
knows that it took the death of his
uncle Ben for Peter Parker to realize
that his actions have consequences and
they can't always save everyone
[Music]
yeah
over here Uncle Ben for young miles it's
the death of his uncle Aaron the
parallel between the two characters is a
brilliant facet of the film that is both
mature and thought-provoking you you
were just just keep going
[Music]
kugo eagle-eyed audience members most
likely picked up on a hearty portion of
the various Easter eggs featured in
spider-man into the spider verse in one
of the films many blinking and missing
moments viewers get a peek at miles as
dad's phone contacts although Jefferson
Davis is trying to call his brother
Aaron you can't help but notice another
more prominent name on the list Steve
Ditko Marvel fanboys will recognize that
as a nod to the late comic book artist
who along with Stan Lee co-created
spider-man and Doctor Strange
however the subtle name-dropping doesn't
stop there
in another scene Myles takes out his
phone to make a call and the audience
yet again gets a glimpse at his phone
book the most obvious attention grabbers
are the names B Bendis alluding to Brian
Michael Bendis and Sarah Pacelli this
duo co-wrote Miles Morales first series
2011's Ultimate Comics spider-man you
probably only notice these subtle
details if names like Ditko Bendis and
Pacelli meant something to you and for
many now adult comic readers in the 90s
and early 2000s that was the case when
it's finally his turn to return to his
own universe John mulaney's Peter porker
aka spider-ham gives miles a touching
farewell humorously gifting him a
massive wooden hammer I want you to have
this before making the jump home before
he ascends he sadly declares that's all
folks
prompting Peter B Parker to ask if he
was allowed to say that quote legally
the line is obviously a reference to the
Looney Tunes character Porky Pig
owned by Warner Brothers who you can
assume has a trademark on the infamous
phrase by questioning the legality of
using the line Peter breaks the fourth
wall to call the audience's attention to
the cartoon pig that isn't porky saying
his famous line
it's a meta nod to a competitor's
classic character but it's humor is
probably lost on children since well
they probably aren't all too familiar
with the concept of copyright
infringement into the spider verse
really starts to gain traction when
Peter B Parker enters the fold but
chubbier more depressed spider-man than
the one from miles as universe during
his introductory scene the audience
learns that this more jaded broken-down
version of Peter ended things with the
mary-jane from his universe because well
she wanted kids and it scared me
although it's presented in a humorous
light this arc of Peter learning that he
can in fact become a good parent is
present throughout the movie for those
clever enough to pick up on it it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to
realize that the relationship between
Peter and Miles is not unlike that of a
father and son Miles the in over his
head apprentice seeks guidance from
Peter the weary master who is so
experienced that he almost can't help
himself from giving advice by the end of
the movie Peter gets to witness
firsthand the effect his presence had on
Miles as heroic growth and it's a
feeling that gives him immense pride in
the climactic final battle Peter says
most parents in the audience surely
understood Peters weighty realization
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]